every day African penguins spend hours
out in the ocean hunting fish to feed
themselves and their chicks the biggest
colony lives at the Stoney Point Nature
Reserve which is on the coast south of
Cape Town Marine Ranger Q & mcgeorge
looks after the colony he works for Cape
nature the Conservation Authority for
the Western Cape at this locality with
only Papa colony that's actually growing
much the other of the 27 other colonies
penguin colonies along our southern
African coastline much them on decline
and some of them are even extinct over
the past century the population has
collapsed down for millions to well
under a hundred thousand overfishing the
oceans means the Penguins have a hard
time finding enough to eat ingesting
plastic waste kills many birds as does
oil in the water another colony is on
dyer island it used to be the biggest
but it too has collapsed money made with
tourist boat trips to the island helps
fund the Dyer Island Conservation Trust
and it's penguin and seabird sanctuary
at gonz by on the mainland with its own
rehabilitation center
cool on e la whoa looks after the sick
and injured it's got a su bite wound and
then now we just clean the wound so he's
going to with us for three weeks and
we'll listen as soon as they recover
penguins play an important role in the
region's ecosystem other sea birds often
settle near their colonies like these
cormorants
seabirds have this interrelationship
interconnectivity we find that the
Penguins you plunge diver who they
co-opt in hunt in packs to actually
bring the food to the surface and allow
the other seabirds to feed this
dependence is very important between all
seabirds if you lose the one you lose
the others despite conservationists best
efforts the number of African penguins
continues to decline if large-scale
fishing continues to deplete stocks the
birds face starvation the fear is that
the species may become extinct in the
not-too-distant future
you